[Musique]
je suis entendra aujourd'hui on va
parler de numérique
mais avant cela je vous demandais
quelque chose de très simple je vous
poser une question et s'il vous plaît je
vous demandais de répondre à cette
question
ma première question toutes les
personnes qui sont dans cette salle là
tout de suite qu'ils n'ont pas de
smartphone
s'il vous plaît les v vous toutes les
personnes qui sont dans cette salle qui
ont un smartphone qui n'ont pas de
connexion internet
s'il vous plaît les vais vous faire
autrement
toutes les personnes qui sont dans cette
salle qui ont déjà fait une recherche
sur google d'une information capitale
les v vous waouh c'est génial faux
brassard merci vous savez quoi
j'aurais pu faire cette expérience un
peu partout dans le monde entier
j'aurai obtenu le même résultat le
numérique aujourd'hui elle est
universelle
c'est pas comme tout le reste c'est pas
comme les infrastructures
c'est pas comme les développements comme
on l'entend les smartphones que vous
utilisez c'est les mêmes qu'on utilise
aux états unis les réseaux téléphoniques
et vous utilisez
c'est les mêmes qu'on utilise partout
les applications que vous utilisez ces
éléments conduisent parrot c'est
pourquoi en afrique aussi un plus 50 0
ça n'explique pas pourquoi n 1 plus 1 15
euro
je sais que vous vous demandez pourquoi
un plus un égale zéro
est ce que vous êtes déjà demandé
pourquoi on parle de numérique pour
l'informatique pour les pour les données
pour les images pour les photos pour les
textes et pourtant quand vous prenez
votre smartphone là tout de suite
vous n'allez pas voir des chiffres m'ont
dit numérique est ce que vous êtes déjà
demandé pourquoi parce que l'ensemble de
l'information dont on parle c'est trouve
stockés de façon numérique on a
l'habitude de compter en base 10 salles
y confronte de 1 jusqu'à 10 donc quand
on arrive à 10 pour écrire 11 on va pas
inventer un autre chiffre
on va écrire 1 1 pour dire vous vous
êtes d'accord avec moi en base 2 c'est
ça le langage numérique
on va compter 2 0 à 1 donc quand on
arrive à 2 comme on n'a pas le droit
d'écrire deux on divise les deux par
deux
et le reste c'est zéro donc un plus un
égale zéro je voudrais vous montrez ce
petit slide away afrique
créée en langage informatique ce que les
héros et d'un an l'ensemble des données
que vous avez sont stockés sur vos
téléphones sur vos smartphones sous ce
format
aujourd'hui la question qu'on va se
poser vu que la technologie de façon
générale aujourd'hui le numérique c'est
le l'un des seuls domaines l'un des
rares domaines dans lesquels l'afrique
n'a pas de retard comment on peut
utiliser ce potentiel là pour développer
nos pays
comment paix basé notre politique sur
cette nouvelle technologie là pour
développer notre pays je vous proposer
quelque chose de simple je vous
proposais des devenir juste le temps de
ma présentation le gouvernement
d'afrique parmi vous il ya des ministres
il y en a certains qui sont déjà
contents il ya des directeurs des
ambassadeurs et moi je suis le président
bien sûr et je vais vous demander aussi
de valider des propositions concrètes
que je vais vous faire aujourd'hui ses
propositions validées comme vous avez
l'habitude de le faire sur tous les
réseaux sociaux quand vous aimez une
publication comment vous faites on
envoie un pouce en l'air on like
c'est ce que je vous propose et je veux
poser un certain nombre de propositions
ceux qui n'aiment pas bien sûr les
propositions envoyées le poussant à
l'envers mais ça vous le faite
discrètement s'il vous plaît pour ne pas
influencer les autres
la première a pris qu'on va poser
aujourd'hui c'est la brique de
l'éducation comment utiliser le
numérique pour développer l'éducation en
afrique
vous savez l'accès à l'éducation est
très difficile et c'est un défi partout
en afrique
comment assurer à nos enfants des
infrastructures scolaires
on est sur un an sur un modèle qui
montre ses limites il faut construire
des écoles il faut envoyer des
enseignants je veux juste vous demandé
d'imaginer une seconde une tablette avec
un chargeur solaire et avec un contenu
interactif
on donne la tablette charger le
continent interactif au village on vous
dit
vos enfants peuvent apprendre de façon
autonome sur cette tablette là ce que je
suis en train de dire pas vous
surprendre mais quelque chose avait déjà
été fait dans ce sens là un exemple
serait comme si que vous voyez sur l'os
l'aide c'est un tablet une charger un
chargeur et un contenu interactif ayant
ses lavandières qu'isabelle suga mithra
qui a fait une expérience extraordinaire
en inde qu'on appelle le trou dans le
mur
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
cette expérience là c'est indien fait la
promotion de l'apprentissage par soit
l'auto apprentissage qu'est-ce qu'il
avait tout simplement il est allé dans
les bidonvilles d'inde
il a ouvert un mur il a un cas serait un
ordinateur dedans il a mis le programme
d'auto formation dessus et les enfants
en passant en revue qui avait une souris
sur l'écran
ils ont commencé à naviguer au bout
d'une semaine savez tous utiliser la
souris
au bout d'un moment ils savaient tous
allés faire des recherches sur internet
il a poussé son expérience loin il a
voulu à faire apprendre l'anglais à des
enfants qui vivaient dans un village de
pêcheurs il a installé un programme qui
apprend l'anglais british seriak
l'accent british et devinez quoi
au bout d'une année les enfants de ce
village parlait l'anglais comme des
vrais british donc aujourd'hui le taux
formation impossible beaucoup de gens me
disent être qu'on peut remplacer un
enseignant arthur c'est clark qui est le
réalisateur de au 10è 2001 odyssée de
l'espace a dit si un enseignant peut
être remplacé par le numérique
il doit l'être donc aujourd'hui on peut
penser notre politique de l'enseignement
de la formation de nos enfants dans les
coins les plus reculés à partir du
numérique
est-ce que vous validez cette
proposition on veut passer à la deuxième
brique c'est la brique de la santé vous
savez en afrique quand malade qu'est ce
qu'on fait on va voir la médecine
traditionnelle
si ça marche pas
on va à la pharmacie on demande dans la
formation de nos ausculté consiste en un
médecin si ça marche pas on va à
l'hôpital
cette démarche est illogique un principe
mais il ya une logique derrière logique
c'est quoi c'est l'accès aux soins la
médecine traditionnelle pourquoi au delà
de nos croyances encore a
fondamentalement caisse des dépôts truc
mais au-delà de cela c'est qu'il suffit
d'une fois des scellés allez y les
corses des langues qui se trouve au
cours de son milieu de la cour de le
faire bouillir de boire un peu et
surtout de se laver avec pour être guéri
pourquoi ne ferait pas pareil avec la
médecine conventionnelle qu'est ce qui
manque
imaginez la même tablette tout de suite
on ne change rien qu'on a utilisées pour
les écoles sur cette tablette
cette fois ci on installe ce qu'on
appelle la consultation virtuel parce
que qu'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est les médecins des qualités dans les
endroits les plus reculés
cette consultation virtuel pour sfr deux
fois par semaine on met dans une case la
tablette qui est autonome complètement
autonome avec un local ont fait des
consultations en ligne et dans ce
domaine des africains ont déjà démontré
toute leur capacité
il ya une tablette qui a été développé
par un camerounais arthur angle qui
permet aujourd'hui de monitorer toutes
les fonctions cardiaques des malades
c'est juste une tablette imaginez cette
tablette connectée avec cette
consultation lancée a dit que le médecin
cardiologue serait n'importe où dans le
monde mais motivé si vous voulez avec ce
moniteur là ils pourraient montrer une
maladie cardiaque
une deuxième expérience c'est
l'échographe par smartphone mais pour
quel smartphone aujourd'hui permet avec
cet outil là
avec cet outil de pouvoir de pouvoir
faire de la consultation à distance à
lire aujourd'hui il est possible avec
son smartphone de pouvoir faire de
l'échographie à distance si nos
populations a accès à tous ces moyens là
là où ils sont je sais pas pourquoi la
médecine ne marcherait pas et c'est pas
de gros investissements dont je vous
parle à ses deux choses qui sont à
portée de main aujourd'hui est-ce que
penser aujourd'hui le numérique pour
importer plus de facilité d'accès aux
soins à nos populations
est ce que c'est une bonne idée est-ce
que vous validé cette proposition
la troisième proposition que je vais
faire aujourd'hui c'est dans le domaine
de la politique
je suis content d'avoir des politiques
dans la salle aujourd'hui la politique
elle se fait autrement on avait des
assemblées nationales qui décide ensuite
aujourd'hui chaque citoyen a la
possibilité d'agir sur la politique
grâce aux réseaux sociaux
notre parole et c'est limite plus à chez
nous d'ailleurs il ya une phrase c'est
là que j'ai vu sur face book l'aude où
ça m'a fait rigoler mais pas possible
cette phrase disait quoi avant facebook
c'est le départ à savais que tu étais
dit que tu es un idiot
m
c'est vrai parce que ce qu'on disait au
trot face à rester en famille mais cette
fois ci si vous dit quelque chose c'est
parti dans le monde entier donc votre
opinion elle compte énormément
pourquoi ne pas envisager aujourd'hui
des modes de gouvernance différentes
nous sociétés ont toujours fonctionné
comme cela collégial on prend des
décisions
pourquoi ne pas imaginer des méthodes
des moyens des outils qui se sont qui se
base sur le numérique pour donner la
parole au peuple pour qu'il puisse
apporter pas sur toutes les questions
pensée sera impossible mais sur des
questions cruciales donner la parole au
peuple
est ce que vous valez délit d utiliser
aujourd'hui le numérique comme -
décision pour donner au peuple qu'ils
puissent agir positivement sur sa
politique est-ce que vous validez la
quatrième proposition que je vais faire
aujourd'hui c'est celle de la culture
beaucoup d'intervenants parler de
culture aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la culture n'a pas de
frontières en réalité c'est difficile de
se centrer sur cette source de toute
façon je pense que d'ici quelques années
d'ici peut-être dix ans 50 ans il y aura
tellement un melting-pot de toutes les
cultures qu'une seule culture ne
dominera pas le monde à ce que le
numérique internet vous a tellement
interconnecté que le génie siens au
courant de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis l'un au courant de ce qui se
passe au tibet il est au courant de tout
ce qui ce qui se passe dans le monde
entier mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour nos cultures les autres de la même
manière qu'ils ont porté leur culture
sur ces moyens de communication il faut
porter une culture sur ces - qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'optionnelle
marmitons en train de faire une soupe
mondial des cultures
chacun apporte son ingrédient est la
seule façon de mettre son ingrédient
dans cette soupe la c'est d'utiliser un
moyen qui communique avec le monde
entier
aujourd'hui nous devons vulgarisons nos
cultures nous devons le portée par le
numérique
est-ce que envisager des politiques plus
engagés pour diffuser notre culture via
le numérique est ce que vous validez
cela
la dernière brique qu'on va poser c'est
celle des l'économie les nerf de la
guerre l'argent
vous savez je suis là aujourd'hui grâce
à l'économie numérique
parce qu'il ya quatre ans j'étais assis
dans mon bureau j'ai un ami qui m'est
très cher il est venu dans mon bureau
tout excité on va créer une société qui
doit faire du numérique on va on va
gagner de l'argent c'est génial il était
tellement enthousiaste que j'écris que
je lui disais non ils allaient me tuer
il est dans la salle c'est gabriel
traoré je vous prie de l'applaudir et à
l'époque on sait associe avec un peu un
troisième ami qui en france qui est
spécialiste de la sécurité informatique
pour créer une société qui s'appelle
vous links ont fait du développement web
ont fait du développement numérique ont
créé des applications
notre matière première c'est le
numérique c'est les héros que vous avez
vu tout à l'heure on vient de finir le
développement de trois applications dont
une qui est d'accord qui permet
aujourd'hui des moniteurs et l'accès aux
cantines dans les écoles malienne les
cantines sont très importantes pour ces
communautés qui sont éloignés pour que
les autres viennent à l'école et nous on
vient définir développé une application
qui permet de monitorer cela vous allez
me dire oui vous êtes des spécialistes
du numérique et pour nous qui ne sont
pas des spécialistes du numérique
je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote la dernière fois je rentrais
démission de kai à presque 500 km de
bamako
j'ai vu beaucoup de poulet avec un
monsieur je me suis dit génial faire je
vais acheter des poulains pas cher parce
que c'est pas beaucoup je vais voir le
vendeur jeudi d'un habituellement les
poulets bio c'est aux alentours de 3000
si je me trompe pas trois mille francs
cfa
je les dis je veux c'est combien le game
et 10 2500 francs cfa jeudi mais c'est
pas possible
quand tu es bande de poulets à 2500
francs c'est votre vous me prenez pour
un baume à quoi ou quoi il me dit non
j'ai mon téléphone le matin
j'appelle bamako jeu les gars ils me
disent 3000 francs jallet 25 cents pour
l'essence
est ce que le numérique n'a pas agi sur
son business
aujourd'hui vous partez un malitel da
c'est à dire le la silicon valley du
mali créé il crée des choses ils
inventent des choses là là a vraiment
l'afrique a un incroyable talent et si
vous arrêtez tout ça je vous assure
si vous arrêtez le numérique tous ces
jeunes seront sans emploi et c'est pas
des gars qui ont étudié dans les grandes
universités
ici ils se sont approprié le numérique
parce qu'ils ont vu tous l'opportunité
qui est là est ce que vous validez
l'idée d'utiliser le numérique pour
développer nos économies différemment
merci je voudrais terminer ma
présentation en vous disant c'est si les
propositions que je viens de vous faire
tout de suite c'est des potentiels tous
ces potentiels là nous devons le
transformer en énergie et nous serons
gagnants
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]